et
avec sa fille actuellement à moscou
claire montagne on n'est pas sereine ces
derniers jours avec le début de la
guerre sa fille lola de 22 ans va
revenir chez elle aux essarts-le-roi les
billets réservés dimanche 27 février en
passant par la finlande ne sont plus
valables l'espace aérien européen a été
fermé aux avions et compagnie aérienne
russe et vol
enfin fondent comme neige au soleil que
le temps d'un clic il est plus dispo etc
externe donc ça devient un peu un peu
tendu quand même et puis on a fini on
comprend que le prochain qu'on trouve il
faut pas réfléchir
plus de deux minutes et donc on a trouvé
un vol pour ankara moscou ankara puis
ankara bové voilà le trajet que va
emprunter lola
malgré une situation habituelle dans la
capitale russe la vie pour les étrangers
devient compliqué
[Musique]
tapie de cash
d'accord
d'accord cette jeune étudiante
yvelinoise est parti à moscou le samedi
19 février
un séjour de trois semaines pour prendre
des cours intensifs de langue russe j'en
ai parlé autour de moi j'ai regardé les
infos j'écoute la radio et en fait quand
je suis parti très peu de gens pensaient
que ça escalade rey à ce point et comme
ce qui était importante pour moi parce
que j'en aurai besoin probablement pour
mon cursus académique et professionnelle
du côté des essarts le roi chez la
famille montagnon la sérénité devrait
revenir l'arrivée de lola à beauvais est
prévue le vendredi 4 mars en fin d'après
midi